[Music]
hi there internet i'm john oliver uh we
are off this week but i wanted to
quickly check back in to talk to you
about a subject that is near and dear to
my heart and that is
rocks that's right rocks
so congratulations whoever just
completed their last week tonight topic
bingo cards but but i'm not going to be
talking to you about just any rocks i'm
going to be talking about specific rocks
although
not straight away because for reasons
that will become clear i'm going to need
to lay some significant groundwork we
really have to ramp up to this one so
before i talk to you about specific
rocks i'm first going to talk to you
about furries and before i talk about
furries i need to talk to you about the
georgia republican gubernatorial primary
remember the rest of my staff is on
vacation right now my family went to an
island i think and i'm here so
we are all where we're supposed to be
now if you know anything about the
georgia primary it's probably the front
runners involved incumbent brian kemp
and challenger david perdue but this
piece isn't about them to be honest i
don't even have time to point out which
is which they're both old white
republican men who look a lot like that
meme of two spider-men pointing at each
other
instead
i want to talk about a third candidate
in the election candice taylor she was
also running in the republican primary
although polling far behind kemp and
perdue at around just four percent so
she had a real uphill battle on her
hands which may be why she came out
swinging in this debate appearance
donald trump won he won
we have a fraudulent pedophile in the
white house i'm going to put the
constitution first and i'm going to put
jesus first every single time and we're
going to fix our schools we're going to
get rid of this anti-white racism and
we're going to get rid of kindergarten
teachers men with beards and lipstick
and high heels teaching our children
we're going to get back to being moral
in georgia now obviously there is a lot
of offensive [ __ ] on display there from
the baseless accusations of voter fraud
to naked racial grievances to anti-trans
panic too and this is the big one how
she spells candice because that is
simply
incorrect
that looks like how a cartoon snake
would pronounce the word candies
but
was that fiery debate performance enough
to win her the primary probably not
since it was this past tuesday and she
lost it um at least i'm assuming that
she lost it we take these ahead of time
so there is a small possibility that she
won but honestly if she did we'll have
deleted this video anyway and pretended
it never happened so if you're watching
this right now that means candice taylor
definitely lost
and
one of these two guys who shared many of
her terrible views but in a more media
savvy package they won instead and if
you're thinking john if you're thinking
john why on earth john
are you devoting one of your precious
few web exclusives which many consider
to be a far superior product to the
dreck you put on television
why are you wasting this yammering on
about a barely scene also ran in a
primary that just ended i would respond
hey
hey
you don't have to be here why are you
watching this to which
you might respond because you promised
me rocks goddammit where are my rocks
and we will get there we will get there
i promise but first
a little more about candice taylor
this was her campaign bus and look you
can put whatever you want on a bus like
jungkook from bts or this big snake
or this although ideally never that but
my point is candace's bus made some
weird choices i don't know whether it's
the i'm the one you've been waiting for
with one emphasise for no clear reason
or the mixture of cursive and stencil
fonts usually reserved for epsy signs
like together is my favorite place to be
or home is where the wine is waiting
or the fact she listed her three
campaign priorities as jesus guns babies
it is the sort of brain dead knee-jerk
culture war buzzword platform that you
would expect to appeal solely to mike
lindell and guess what you'd be
absolutely right because she once
tweeted mike lindell understands our
movement for jesus guns and babies
but for whatever reason the handshake of
a deranged pillow baron didn't do much
for her numbers and candice seemingly
spent the final months of her campaign
how any republican who desperately wants
attention would and that is by
frantically seeking out culture war
issues that would give her campaign
traction and people do like to see a
fighter
don't they which is presumably why
she posted this campaign video
the governor's race in georgia has four
establishment politicians
and then there's candace
taylor and i'm one of you
that's the whole clip
we didn't edit that down that is the
complete video that she posted
along with a tweet that said that's it
that's the tweet
and
yeah candice i guess i guess
i guess agree to agree on that one i
suppose also not for nothing that is the
least convincing portrayal of a boxer
that i have ever seen and i have seen ed
sheeran's shape of you video
he looks like ron weasley failing a
zumba class
now
for a while
for a while it seemed like candace's
chosen enemy would be the manufactured
panic the public schools have been
formally accommodating the needs of
furries which brings me as promised to
furries
if you are not aware earlier this year a
bunch of conservatives fell for some
very weird online rumors about what was
happening in schools and i will let
nebraska state senator bruce bostelman
explain
i'm a little shocked
i guess is what i would put it it's
called something called furries
we don't know what furries are it's
where school children
dress up as animals cats or dogs during
the school day
meow and they bark and now schools are
wanting to put litter boxes in the
schools for these children
to use
how is this sanitary
[Applause]
i mean
none of that happened bruce
[Applause]
first and this is the least of the
problems here dogs don't [ __ ] in litter
boxes
but also neither do furries that is not
what furries do what they do do is they
use regular toilets where elaborate
fursuits and many offer art commissions
where you can get yourself done up as a
sexy river otter at very reasonable
prices they
are harmless but candice taylor
an adult seeking office remember
actually ran on this anti-furry issue
issuing 10 proposed executive orders one
of which instructed no fury related
items will be worn in schools also
tweeting the furry days are over when
i'm governor which is just an all-time
thing to tweet
honestly it's an all-time thing to say
just try it walk into any room and
announce the furry days are over when
i'm governor do it right now and see if
you don't feel an electric rush of power
don't explain yourself why should you
after all you're the governor and furry
days are over
and the replies to that tweet are
exactly the sort of response that you
would hope for and expect from the furry
community one person said if schools are
for academics not fairy tales then how
come people still teach supply side
economics
to which i say
roasted
well several others simply posted furry
cartoon asses and if you
absolutely had to reduce the furry
presence online right down to his bones
critiques of conservative economic
theory and fuzzy butt shots really are
the guiding principles of the whole
movement anyway
i mentioned candice taylor's ten
executive orders she initially only
released nine of them and made it clear
that number 10 was going to be a major
drop even spending days hyping it up
online saying evil cannot be negotiated
with and must be crushed eo number 10 is
going to shake the nation stay tuned
which yeah you're right it does sound
pretty major doesn't it and you know
what when number 10 finally dropped
it turned out candice was right
the new world order is here
and they told us it was
coming it's a battle far greater than
what we see in the natural
it is a war
between good and evil
[Music]
yeah candice isn't [ __ ] around
she tweeted that alongside i am the only
candidate willing to stand up to the
satanic cabal the georgia guidestones
must be demolished that was the closing
argument of her campaign raising the
obvious question hey candace taylor what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
and at this point it is finally time to
talk about rocks and
not just rocks remember specific rocks
and specifically the georgia guide
stones because it turns out they are a
roadside attraction in alberts county
georgia and taylor is actually not the
only one with a sense of animosity
towards them the guidestones are the
centerpiece of a lot of online
conspiracy theories which kind of makes
sense they were erected centuries ago by
ancient druids except they weren't they
were put up in 1980
and the man who commissioned them did so
under a pseudonym there are also a
functioning astronomical calendar and
some think they have paranormal
properties like this guy
when you take pictures of it
[Applause]
when you put your head down in there
like this and look through it the ball
of energy comes through that sucker man
i try to get up here three to five times
a week you know what i for one believe
him not about the blue orb that is
ridiculous what i believe about is the
scheduling i fully believe that some
days that man thinks to himself oh no
i've only been up to see the ball of
energy twice this week i'm gonna have to
move some stuff around
the stones also feature massive
engravings that have been the subject of
a lot of investigation as you can see on
this episode of the history channels
decoded
looks like there's a bunch of different
languages
i just googled this and we've got
english spanish swahili hindi hebrew
arabic chinese and russian it seems like
to me it seems like a weird new 10
commandments
is it 10
[Music]
10
that's weird
yeah good catch
is it
is it a good catch
is that the weirdest thing about the
20-foot stonehenge outside of atlanta
the number 10 also to television editors
everywhere next time you're sitting in
the edit bay watching footage of a
middle-aged man slowly count to ten
don't put it to dramatic music you can
just edit it out people will honestly
thank you in fact here are 10 reasons
why you should do that what but they are
right in that the stones feature weird
aspirational instructions mostly vague
catch-all edicts like protect people and
nations with fair laws and balance
personal rights with social duties and
guide reproduction wisely improving
fitness and diversity you know some
broad feel good precepts mixed in with
some light to medium eugenics but but
the line that the controversy focuses on
reads maintain humanity under 500
million in perpetual balance with nature
and i will say at this point you could
see how anyone who believes in say a
satanist new world order cabal might see
that as a bit of a red flag and as long
as these stones have been around which
is again
since 1980
people have been scared shitless by them
some believed they were a satanic altar
while in 2014 conspiracy theorists cited
the guidestones as proof that the ebola
outbreak would kill off much of humanity
and in 2018 marjorie taylor green oh
yeah she is involved here too i mean how
would she not be
she endorsed the idea that the
guidestones revealed a world genocide
plot and after hearing a bunch of
theories that dumb
instinctively i am tempted to defend the
guidestones and point out that a far
more common interpretation is that they
are directions for rebuilding
civilization after an apocalypse which
would make some sense given that they
were built at the height of the cold war
and the client who went by the alias
robert christian by the way had told the
builder he wanted it to be capable of
withstanding the most catastrophic
events i could also point out
the ridiculousness of thinking that some
sort of global illuminati
wrote down their plot for killing off 95
percent of humanity on a giant granite
post-it note
and left their secret plan somewhere no
conservative would ever find it rural
georgia
i am tempted to say all of that but here
is where this piece gets a little weird
that's right at this point
not with the snake boss
not with that thing that you had to look
at earlier
and are having to look at again now
this right here is the weird part
because while researching this piece as
far as we knew
no one had ever definitively uncovered
who was responsible for the guide stones
none of the reporting that we looked at
ever dug that deep and it was only after
we wrote everything that you've seen up
to this point right now that we
discovered this kind of shitty 2015
documentary from a born-again christian
filmmaker who decided to investigate the
guide stones in it the producers tricked
the one man who knows robert christian's
real identity and who had promised never
to reveal it into allowing them to open
this case containing their
correspondence on camera and in doing so
seemingly revealed that the guidestones
were ordered by a man named a man named
dr herbert kirsten and if that
documentary is right and kirsten is the
man behind the guide stones that is
pretty troubling because he was a doctor
from fort dodge iowa with multiple
interests conservation certainly
population control
absolutely but he also wrote at least
two letters in newspapers praising david
duke yeah that's david duke the clan
leader and neo-nazi arguing among other
things that duke voices many beliefs
held by reasonable americans it is
unfortunate that more acceptable public
figures are not pushing similar views
which is the sort of thing that makes a
line like guide reproduction wisely hit
a little bit different now doesn't it
so unfortunately this web extra which
was supposed to be a light piece about
this silly southern fried stonehenge
suddenly got much less fun which is very
disappointing i mean
what other roadside attractions are
harboring dark past how many mini golf
dinosaurs
are secretly race zealots
who rolled up this giant ball of twine
hitler it doesn't bear thinking about
and i know that you like me may be
blindsided by this revelation although
i'm also willing to bet that others saw
this coming the very moment i said a
monument in georgia i mean
this is a state that carved confederate
generals into the side of a mountain
it's not like white supremacist
stonework is light on the ground there
but in the end
i guess what this really means is that
reluctantly i do have to hand it to
candice taylor in a way not to her
policies which are terrible or her
platform which is incoherent or her
campaign ads as which are ridiculous or
her bus which is very bad or her
position on furries which is extremely
funny or her ability to spell her own
name which again is just objectively
wrong that's not how you spell that
but i will admit that when it comes to
the georgia guidestones she may have
been partially right albeit for
completely wrong reasons when she
suggested that they were a problem which
is totally heartbreaking because if
there's one thing that should bring our
country together is a good mysterious
roadside attraction so if you live in
georgia or anywhere and you have a few
hundred tons of granite lying about why
not build your own functioning
astronomical clock one that doesn't
reference eugenics put your own
mysterious rules on it like i don't know
the furry days are over when i'm
governor
that's a good one i promise you if you
build it they will come i know at least
one guy who will come three to five
times a week
thank you so much for watching this
we're back on june 5th goodbye
you